ils sont sur la grande scène pour un
cours amateurs et passionnés assisté ce
week-end un stage particulier leur
professeur fabrice lambert vient
échanger sur son travail partagé c'est
secret c'est ce qu'il faudrait faire le
plus souvent possible
ne rien garder partager transmettre et
je crois que c'est très important ce
travail là dans la dranse d'ouvrir à
cette générosité générosité c'était un
engagement envers l'autre et je pense
que le mouvement et fondateur aussi dans
cet acte de transmettre un stage adapté
à tous pour entrer dans la dernière
création de la compagnie aujourd'hui
sauvage l'artiste qui travaille le corps
en mouvement et chorégraphies l'espace
lui aussi en mouvement
[Musique]
voir un spectacle
autrement on voit je pense un spectacle
autrement quand on ya une certaine
manière participé ou quand on a goûté
des matières l'énergie la chorégraphie
de ce spectacle là c'est un autre oeil
s'est aiguisé à notre sensation
vis-à-vis du corps et l'espace deux
jours de stage auquel a participé une
vingtaine de personnes
j'ai déjà participé à un précédent
projet qu'avait mené fabrice lambert
avec le théâtre nous resterons sur terre
et je voulais voir comment comment le
travail évolue s il y avait un lien avec
ce qu'il avait fait précédemment
et puis en lien avec la prochaine
création travail et le ressenti de son
corps jusqu'où on peut aller retrouver
l'archaïsme qui est en nous et qu'on
perd un peu avec une société super
moderne et trop un peu trop mangé par la
technologie
une restitution a eu lieu ce dimanche la
pièce professionnelle elle sera à voir
le 29 mars prochain